show up if you want to have success as
an entrepreneur you need to follow
through you need to be trustworthy and
you need to show up hi I'm Evan
Carmichael I believe that hungry
entrepreneurs deserve help and today I
made the mistake of bringing my vest but
in when it was a really rainy day it
wasn't raining in the morning and I had
to leave and it's pouring outside I get
to the garage I'm hopping on my best bug
crank up the motor ready to go a guy
pulls up next to me and stops me and
says hey buddy you don't want to go out
there it's raining I said hey thanks for
your concern that's really cool but I
gotta be somewhere so I gotta go and
said no no no no no you don't understand
it's pouring you're gonna get soaked is
a huge thunderstorm out there and it's
true you know I only had a light jacket
on some pants I didn't have any my gear
with me and I told him hey I really
appreciate it but I have to be somewhere
I have no choice I gotta go and I
thanked him and I left and I got soaked
on my way but that's running a business
you have to show up you have to be
reliable you have to deal with that crap
you could be like that guy and not show
up and not follow through and not
deliver because it's hard because
something got in the way because you
have an excuse people don't care about
your excuses you need to deliver you
need to show up even though it's hard
even though it's raining all around you
you want to have success as an
entrepreneur show up for those you're
watching you know the drill you like the
video please give it a thumbs up below
and always next want to do more for you
and here I want to hear you get to think
leave a comment below show up leave a
comment underneath I want to hear from
you and I want to help with your
business if you have another question
please leave in the comments below I
really do appreciate seeing those come
in and I always read them so thank you
show up and i'll see you on the next
episode
you